je reçois maintenant michel houellebecq
le phénomène des lettres françaises de
cette fin de siècle l'auteur des
sulfureuses particules élémentaires
dresse le bilan de son succès littéraire
et nous parle de ses projets d'avenir
bref voici houellebecq un livre ouvert
michel houellebecq bonsoir vous est
demandé de venir parce que c'est la
dernière émission je dirais comme les
autres après c'est cannes donc on
voulait que vous soyez notre dernier
invité de l'année parce que vous avez
marqué l'année voilà alors les
particules élémentaires donc je rappelle
chez flammarion sous là sous la
direction du caire de raphaël sorin
alors évidemment ce cas disons le est il
plus étonnant dans le bouquin c'est
cette espèce de haine de la permissivité
hérité de 68 et le fait que la fin de
l'autorité la fin de la religion la fin
du couple
ça rend les gens dingues et si j'ai bien
compris deviennent des particules
élémentaires un peu des électrons libres
comme ça alors ça ça a effectivement été
choquant parce que c'est vrai et la
deuxième chose qui a aussi choqué les
gens c'est finalement ce que vous disiez
sur le clonage en disant qu'il fallait
dépasser la la dichotomie eugénisme
égale nazisme pour aller plus loin et
vous disiez même que vous étiez plus
choqué par l'avortement que par le
clonage voilà j'en arrive maintenant à
ma question ce n'est pas moi qui parle
c'est le personnage avez vous souvent
répété donc a eu cette ambiguïté qui
fait que le roman de houellebecq est
devenue la sphère houellebecq mais enfin
tranquillement enfin comment vous avez
vécu ça c'est à dire que vous avez passé
votre temps finalement à répondre sur
des interviews précédente et à vous
justifier de ce que disent et vos
personnages en fait le clonage s'agirait
une toute petite place dans le roman
c'est clair que j'ai mis un prologue et
un épilogue qui répondait au prologue
qui sont un peu en dépendant du roman et
où on bascule dans la science fiction en
fait par le par le clonage et
l'immortalité et je ne pensais pas que
ça ferait un effet aussi foudroyant que
tout le monde me parle de ça
pour moi ce qu'une espèce d'hypothèses
un prof à quelque chose de littéraires
pour rajouter une espèce d'éclairage
leur manque est en fait tout le monde a
beaucoup insisté je m'en a parlé de ça
parce que c'est vrai que la littérature
s'empare tellement rarement de la
modernité de l'avenir de la science
c'est ce qui se passe en ce moment avec
le bouquin de dantec
vous avez sûrement lu babylon babies
c'est-à-dire qui d'un seul coup les gens
sont surpris et c'est bien parce que la
littérature lui de raconter des petites
intrigues de coucheries à droite à
gauche raconte de la réalité
d'aujourd'hui est bon en fait moi pour
moi c'était de la science fiction mais
je me suis demandé si c'était une si
mauvaise idée le clonage tout compte
fait au fond bon j'étais surpris que au
départ que tout le monde déteste ça un
tel point que l'idée soit si choquant
donc j'y ai repensé depuis je me suis
dit pourquoi pas ou une reproduction par
clonage
oui pourquoi pas pourquoi pas ça mais
c'est vrai que ça me choque pas
énormément vous êtes est sans doute le
premier à en parler dans la littérature
de cette brouille survenue en saxe a
fait ce choc là et puis aussi ce que je
disais tout à l'heure c'est à dire cette
remise en question de l'héritage de 68
où je caricature certes mais enfin dans
votre roman les serial-killer sont
quelque part les héritiers des hippies
donc c'est vrai que c'est des choses qui
sont difficiles à entendre pour les oui
mais ça fait comme on me l'a aussi je
pensais que ce serait plus calme parce
que je me mettais dit que 68 ça faisait
quand même trente ans donc on pouvait en
parler calmement comme d'un truc
appartenant l'histoire qu'on en fait
problème c'est que les gens sont encore
au pouvoir quand ils ont beaucoup et les
gens qu'il avait 20 ans 68 ils ont 50
ans madre ils ont ils ont bien résisté
alors effectivement il est plein de gens
qui l'ont mal pris oui pour moi c'était
assez lointain enfin c'était moins de la
haine quand guy lancer fluence est un
peu de la préhistoire et pour beaucoup
de gens c'est là c'est leur histoire
donc vous avez comme un journée cela
écrit j'aime bien l'expression vitrifiés
la rentrée je trouve que ce beau et
assez juste
vous en êtes aujourd'hui à 265 mille
exemplaires ce qui est bien vous gagnez
de l'argent et pour ça alors vous avez
un nouveau look maintenant on faisait le
look françois valéry quoi oui j'ai su me
suis aperçu que ça ressemblait françois
valéry oui c'est vachement bien
mais c'est étonnant
j'ai peut-être faire des reprises de
france paul van haver on va reparler
après avec votre ami burgalat oui alors
maintenant si vous avez envie de faire
un bouquin pour dire que finalement la
vie est belle quand on a de l'argent et
qu'on habite en irlande
est-ce que sur le plan marketing ça va
poser des problèmes si vous êtes en mer
dès maintenant pour faire un livre en
disant que la vie est belle ou non mais
là bon non mais je bondis c'est vrai
qu'on perd le droit de se plaindre
ouais mais ça même dans la vie privée
j'ai plus le droit de dire je suis
malheureux personne ne veut même pas ce
que c'est visiblement pas vrai et c'est
ça donc je vais faire des trucs plus
plus bizarre ça je vous fais confiance
revienne parce qu'il ya des choses
bizarres aussi mais je veux le faire
publier des poèmes
oui on en parlait justement il
m'apparaît de la rentrée non je jouais à
pour terminer sur les particules
élémentaires et après on passera à
l'avenir
c'est vrai qu'on regarde on va regarder
un petit sujet parce que vous n'avez pas
eu le goncourt donc on en a assez parlé
surtout ici et dans cette émission
françois nourissier un jour nous a dit
que lui entre les camps ce qui le
concerne il aurait bien décerner le
goncourt à michel houellebecq et on va
regarder ça magnéto est alors
houellebecq ça c'est la question que
c'est quand même le roman qui a marqué
la rentrée ou et welbeck pour moi c'est
une question sérieuse je le défendrai
c'est un secret
de l'avoir éliminé avant la bataille
finale je pense que ce n'était une
erreur je crois que c'est une erreur
il n'aurait sans doute pas trouvé à
l'académie goncourt de majorité pour
avoir le prix mais au moins le haut et y
aurait-il été vaincue dans la dans le
dernier combat dans la dernière bataille
à un contre b&o dupeux du fort contre et
dupont ouais ça aurait été mieux que
c'était cette élimination tout d'un coup
il est il est tombé il est tombé à l'eau
là on l'a plus jeunes heureux je
regrette on faisait pas peur que le prix
80 18 soit un peu comparé aux prix
mazeline en 1900 enfin aux primes à zlin
à la ferme adeline en 32 et en toutes
choses égales ou inégale d'ailleurs je
l'aide pour nos amis téléspectateurs que
le cerin n'avait pas été couronnés et
madeline avait été couronnée alors je
pense que pour le consensus n'est pas
marvin on ne sait pas si houellebecq tu
seras céline mais je il n'en reste pas
moins que l'événement jusqu'à
aujourd'hui de la rentrée 98 c'était
l'apparition de houellebecq pour son son
second roman on l'a occulté
je le regrette voilà c'était donc
françois nourissier dans cette émission
le jour où le prix goncourt avait été
décerné à paul constans leur paule
constant michel houellebecq
vous avez dit que vous préfériez encore
que ce soit paul constans colis des
rôles ah oui oui parce que olivier rolin
son côté fo bon livre ouais alors que
bon paule constant mais il est moyen
sans plus quoi vous été assez violent
après cette affaire du prix goncourt
parce que moi je vous ai vu sur une
chaîne se balade c'est idir les jurés
étaient payés aux immigrés t d'avoir dit
çà ou non au bas non parce que tout le
monde le
le monde le sait oui mais mais j'étais
pas trop
fâché pas c'était un peu du dépit quand
même nous ont posé la question mais moi
je suis peut-être violence en s'en
rendre compte je me rends pas compte moi
j'ai l'impression que c'était une
évidence bowie mais ceci dit toutes les
vérités sont pas toujours bonnes à dire
mais ceci dit c'est assez bourrin
nourricier là ouais enfin c'est quand on
est tous là donner le prix lui quand on
est très vieux en fait il ya un moment
de sincérité qui bouscule tous enfin
c'est ça va c'est bizarre mais c'est pas
très grave
non alors d'abord c'est pas grave je
n'ai pas vendu 260 vous avez exemplaires
aujourd'hui c'est pas fini ensuite j'ai
quand même eu le prix novembre c'est pas
grand chose mais cette joie bien
toujours 200 mille francs dont plus de
partir de partir en irlande c'est pour
les impôts ou pour avoir le total look
écrivain non c'est pas pour le look
écrivains en fait ouais c'est vrai qu'on
paye moins d'impôts on paye que la
cotisation sécu par ailleurs j'ai envie
de prendre à parler anglais mais ça
c'est un peu une autre raison c'est que
vous en fait j'ai plein d'ennemis et
finalement je suis pas très doué en
polémiques et dans le monde anglo saxon
il ya un truc très agréable que c'est
que personne ne connaît et les gens qui
me connaissent sont des amis donc c'est
exact c'est exactement comme à mes
débuts au frein et j'ai aussi beaucoup
d'amis enfin disons d'amis mais je vous
rassure et aussi beaucoup de gens nient
qu'ils considèrent votre livre comme un
livre important à la plus plus compliqué
expliqué bon par exemple dans dont
beaucoup de romans du xixème siècle
il ya des personnages qui parlent
français avec des romans allemands
russes parce que c'était la langue
allant de l'élite la langue de l'élite
maintenant indiscutablement c'est
l'anglais donc j'ai envie de mettre des
passages en anglais je parle pas très
bien anglais jusqu'au col d'apprendre
oui j'apprends je progresse vous il ya
quelqu'un alors je vais vous le dire ça
au passage comme ça qu'on a connue grâce
à vous parce que c'est un ami à vous
c'est noguez qui est un type formidable
on l'a invité ici il vient pas souvent
la télé nos gaza on l'a invité ici ça
s'est très très bien passé
bon je dis ça parce que quand il y avait
le procès de l'espace du possible
vous avez fait un procès parce que vous
citiez la leur vrai nom et vous disiez
d'ici passer des trucs pas enfin que
voulait pas qu'on dise en tous les cas l
oms qui vous avez attaqué et noguez jeu
relevé ça c'est intéressant il dit on
est en pleine marchandisation du
discours on ne pourra plus dire coca
cola c'est de la merde oui mais ils ont
la pub pour s'exprimer et nous on n'a
pas le droit de dire ma toyota a des
ratés
c'est le truc le plus emmerdant qui me
soit arrivée en fait ça risque de si on
a plus si j'avais plus moi comme je cite
constamment beaucoup de choses de la vie
quotidienne y compris des noms de marque
si j'ai plus le droit d'expression
surgit quand russell va avoir du mal oui
je pense que nos gaz à raison de
s'insurger et c'est pour ça que j'en
parle parce qu'il n'est pas question que
le et la pub et que les autres n'est
rien c'est ma ronde dominique noguez est
l'auteur d'un très bon lit pour fait que
pas vu assez de succès à l'époque
c'était les derniers jours du monde et
qu'un des premiers romans apocalyptique
en fait fin de millénaire
mais je sais ça m'a gens qui partent de
biarritz est venu ici vous a raconté son
histoire sur lénine qui avait rencontré
les surréalistes et linda voilà il est
très étonnant et c'est vraiment
quelqu'un qu'on a eu plaisir à écouter
qui est un peu comme vous quelqu'un qui
n'aime pas trop les médias 40e rang
fermé comme ça mais quand y quand il
raconte ses bouquins en plus 4 c'est
génial alors parler de vos projets
maintenant parce que quand même bon
larmes a fini l'année les particules en
continu alors à la rentrée vous publier
un recueil de poèmes c'est vrai oui oui
c'est vrai et
certes pour ce bon jeu plus un recueil
de poèmes ce genre je vois à peu près ce
que je vais faire un jour n'est pas très
long et puis certains poèmes je vais
essayer de les dire avec de la musique
alors justement avec bürgel s'est fait
un disque il ya un disque est sorti
produit par bertrand burgalat qui
s'appelle au coeur de tricatel alors
vous faites là dessus vous faites un
morceau voit pour le moment il ya juste
un morceau ces séjours que la basse et
ça fait jour club etc etc et celle rives
de la boum avec quelques nappes de
violons en passant aéroports et là vous
êtes parti pour faire un vrai un vrai
disque entier avec avec d'organes à
howie une dizaine de titres une dizaine
de titres
oui mais bon je ne sais pas chanter je
pense que d'aucuns dont là dedans ya
peut-être quelques titres où ça peut
aller de dire avec de la musique
sinon je pense que plus généralement ça
serait mieux qu'il ya un autre
interprète que moi je pense que je suis
bon pour faire tes paroles mais pour 20
puis je pense j'ai pas du tout le jeu
pas capable de me produire sur scène
enfin ça m'intimide trop jeu c'est
quelqu'un de très bien burgalat kevrenn
très connu enfin il ya un numéro de
technikart
on parle et c'est vrai que dans le coeur
de tricatel il ya valérie lemercier qui
est son ancienne compagne
et puis une reprise de marie lou a
indiqué nick cave qui fait une reprise
de marie lou de polnareff est très très
bien alors c'est vrai que c'est de faire
une tournée des plages
c'est un peu exagéré il ya un an on va
ailleurs le 2 juillet 2 et 3 puis à
prêcher pas très bien ouais mais pour
faire quoi en bas moi j'ai envie de
faire au moins une fois dire des poèmes
avec de la musique ont pu avancer pour
ça oui oui moi je fais ça l'est les
autres aussi d'ailleurs mais les autres
ils chantent dans les municipalités
peuvent vous inviter à avoir on peut
avoir houellebecq pour une soirée
musicale
oui on peut essayer un message à donner
des idées aux autres faites attention
puis alors on est vraiment dans
l'actuelle parce qu'il ya le film qui
sort votre précédent livre qui
s'appelait extension du domaine de la
lutte donc qui est le film est fait par
philippe harel qui a fait la femme
défendue et isabelle carré et qui a fait
aussi les randonneurs donc ça vous avez
vous déjà des choses que j'ai vu le film
a vu le film j'ai pas il est pas mixer
mais il est monté et alors vous êtes
déçu pas déçu non non je
je suis content moi je me suis bon en
fait extension humaines de la lutte c
c'est un livre vachement marrant par
moments il y avait vraiment des scènes
drôles mais quand même le fond est
restée règlement triste et on s'est fait
oui moi ça m'a effaré par moments je me
suis dit que c'était courageux de faire
un film aussi hocini lèchefrite j'ai
pris conscience du nihilisme de votre
livre en voyant le film a plu c'est même
pire que ça parce que j'ai participé au
scénario en l'envoyant le truc comme ça
un carnet oui j'ai eu un moment de
terreur mais c'est vrai que par moments
c'est drôle aussi même fond allez on
vous connaît la vie du cadre moyen est
désespérant langage aussi les ailes de
le part les cadres qui est ordinaire
invoquait alors là vous allez partir
faisait peur
d'abord est ce que est ce qu'on va
trouver un cinéaste qui aura le jeu
dirait le talent pour adapter des
particules élémentaires est ce que déjà
vous avez été contacté par des par des
cinéastes belges et ouais mais ça je ne
sais pas mais en fait philippe harel est
arrivé au bon moment
c'est dire que ça faisait déjà trois ans
que j'avais écrit extension est donc en
fait ça me dérangerait pas de refaire un
scénario comme elle âgée peut là par
contre les particules élémentaires non
j'ai pas trop envie d'y penser
personnellement je veux bien que des
gens le fassent mais j'ai d'accord je ne
vois pas replonger dedans 5 tôt pour
apprendre ou alors vous allez partir en
voyage là ça peut d'ailleurs inspiré
votre prochain livre parce que vous êtes
traduit vous être traduit dans 20 pays
vous êtes obligés de partir d'aller
faire ça vous embête pas les séances de
signatures comme ça avec les gens qui
vous intéresse à vous comme si vous
connaissez depuis toujours et qui vous
parle d'un vrai dire j'en ai encore
jamais fait à l'étranger
ouais mais j'ai beau j'ai fait pas mal
d'interviews déjà et je me suis rendu
compte qu'ils avaient plus de
différences entre les deux pays même
proche que je my way est seulement par
exemple les anglais quand il faut une
critique de libre raconte beaucoup plus
l'histoire que
que les français en lisant des critiques
j'avais l'impression presque les
particules élémentaires et est un
thriller
la question qui se pose a été les
français considère qu'on la lui aussi la
halle où il répété en mettent ils
donnent leur avis oui c'est très
différent et les allemands c'est encore
autre chose enfin il était dans belgique
oui oui j'ai déjà remarqué qu'en
belgique il ya une plus grande liberté
d'esprit qu'ici sur tout un tas de
sujets les gens sont plus libres sont
moins politiquement correct en france on
est dedans par contre tant celui-ci sont
au pire
ah ouais c'est bien alors je vais
terminer simplement sur une phrase je
suppose que vous allez en dire mais moi
c'est une phrase de vous que je trouve
formidable si je me sens parfois très
proche de moi même mon favori est ce que
ça vous arrive dans deux styles souvent
en ce moment me sentir très proche de
vous même
mais non là j'essaye de m'écarter
justement pour pour des poèmes parce que
c'est beaucoup plus éclaté quand même
des poèmes enfin donc je non contraire
lâchez pas très proche de moi même parce
que je je mets des choses que je trouve
bien mais eux mais je trouve très
bizarre d avoir écrite moi même donc je
m'écarte un peu de moi même les
particules élémentaires sur la fin ces
personnages là vous commencez à les
trouver lourd je crois pas que j'aurais
fait 600 pages que j'ai fait un accent
mais je pensais en avoir un peu marre de
moi même des personnages de ce que je me
doutais bien qu'on ne mélange jamais
personne n'a ri c'était c'était le
problème des ans mais en même temps
c'est c'est un compliment quand on vous
mélangez au personnage c'est que c'est
qu'on y croit on se dit là pas pu
inventer
en tous les cas ce que je peux vous dire
pour conclure c'est qu' il est très rare
qu'un livre marque autant une année
littéraire c'est pas arrivé s'est même
pas quand est-ce que c'est arrivé pour
la dernière fois à passer de l'année
houellebecq
ouais ouais ben on va continuer alors un
restait toujours guy vous êtes vraiment
très en forme la retraite françois
valéry rester comme ça mais oui mais oui
mais je mais c'est le champion est bien
son programme si vous avez un petit
alzette mois blanc vert qu'à l'époque
quand même oui mais j'ai pensé qu'on
soit il et peroxydée complètement
françois d'essayer de faire un peu
ringard pop
merci michel houellebecq ont crédibilisé
je rappelle le titre du livre si besoin
est ça s'appelle les particules
élémentaires donc et c'est chez
flammarion
je reçois maintenant l'écrivain
essayiste et journaliste gilles perrault
pour la parution chez fayard de sa
lettre ouverte à deux juges françaises
des corps et des lacs loucedé au nord de
l'ardenne et sans raimundo des peña
forte
un livre dans lequel perron stigmatise
la lutte antiterroriste engagées contre
les indépendantistes basques et nous
promet l'éclatement des nations au sein
de l'union européenne
voici donc notre ami hétéro salut alors
bon vous vous présente plus mais quand
même il ya eu les beaucoup de bouquins
qui ont fait grand bruit les
parachutistes l'orchestré rouge le
dossier 51 le pull-over rouge le secret
du roi avant 3 thomas sur les premiers
services secrets du temps de la
monarchie et notre ami le roi évidemment
auquel je faisais allusion consacré au
roi du maroc hassan ii alors cette
lettre deux juges françaises vous
retrouvez en fait votre première
vocation vous avez commencé comme avocat
lab de nouveau vous redevenez avocat
mais cette fois de la cause dacos basque
alors je t'ai vu le figaro lundi les
nouvelles cadiou faire plaisir il ya 700
élus étaient réunis à bilbao qui ont
demandé un état basque une assemblée des
municipalités basque
pour une institution souveraine disons
qui les amènerait à l'indépendance alors
parlez nous de la spécificité basse
parce que c'est vrai que c'est pas
n'importe quelle région le pays basque
non voilà c'est un peuple c'est une
culture c'est une histoire et tout ça a
droit à un état
1 les basques c'est une langue que
personne ne le comprend voilà la nuit
des tirs d'armé avec des bases que vous
dites oui se réfugier dans leur lent à
ben oui alors il était totalement
inexplicable alors là je me suis rendu
compte que les basques s'étaient pas
tout à fait l'équivalent donc c'est un
peuple qui a été martelé 1 et tout
dernièrement notamment sous la dictature
franquiste qui a été à la pointe de la
lutte contre franco mais qui depuis des
siècles lutte pour la préservation de
son identité
et puis la répression a continué il faut
le dire après la moyenne on va y venir
la voir
vous dites pour parler de la spécificité
des bases vous dites par exemple quand
big cents ellis arras où on lui dit
alors vous partez à bilbao vous
expatrier ai dit non il dit alors on dit
souvent oui mais maintenant les basques
a plus de problème parce que là c'est la
démocratie et c'est vrai que roanne est
ce que juan carlos est votre ami le roi
non non mais bien c'est vrai mais bien
le cas oui oui j'ai beaucoup d'estimé
pour cet homme là qui a eu
l'intelligence de passer pour un crétin
sous franco oui de façon à être nommé
successeur et qui a répliqué arrêté le
plan de match herrero et 2000 al delboy
180 absolument non non c'est a certes
ravi le roi lui pour deux oui mais
vraiment mais simplement bas les basques
ont droit détail c'est parce que la
démocratie n'est ce pas tomber parce
qu'en france aussi en 54 y avait la
démocratie est quand même le problème
algérien et ben oui voilà donc la
démocratie ne suffit pas alors on nous
dit à mes sont déjà autonome ils ont
moins de liberté de la wii mais il
voudrait ouais encore plus de liberté
est ce que vous dites est là ou là où
vous êtes livré force et parce qu'il
s'inscrit je dirais dans l'actualité
européenne vous dites mais l'europe peut
permettre de régler le problème basque
comme il peut régler le problème corse
parce que voulez vous êtes d'accord avec
raymond barre
si les corses veulent leur indépendance
qu'ils l'apprennent un la catalogne vous
dit jean despujols ça se passe bien et
que l'europe pourrait leur permettre
d'être indépendant toile arrive pour moi
l'europe si vous voulez c'est un train
qui passe l'année dessiner après et qui
peut ramasser des petites nations
on était resté sur le quai il ya des
grandes nations qui ont vécu leur vie et
ces acquis sont installés en première
classe avec des billets et puis la
petite nation qui sont restés sur le
train et sur le quai et puis quand elle
monte dans le temps l'heure nous n'avez
pas de billet bien l'europe c'est
l'occasion de distribuer des cétacés
c'est assez séduisant vous dit
effectivement que on peut rien répondre
à ça vous dit
le pays basque a autant de le droit
d'exister que le luxembourg oui c'est
vrai qu'on voit pas très bien pourquoi
il y aurait le luxembourg est pas le
pays évidemment alors c'est vrai aussi
vous fait remarquer que tout ça n'est
pas figé parce que qu'ils auraient prévu
le divorce à l'amiable entre lacieko
hélas la slovaquie les causes qu'ils
veulent pendant qu est-ce qui va être
indépendant belgique qui va éclater
évidemment dit au sujet de la belgique
d'ailleurs le problème n'est pas de
savoir si ça va éclater mais quand non
oui bah c'est acquis c'est acquis s'il
n'avait pas le problème de bruxelles
serait depuis longtemps mais là ils se
bouffent le nez sur bruxelles ça arrive
de retarder mais la belgique est en état
de sécession bien sûr alors vous
comparez votre argumentation vous
comprenez que l'algérie et vous vous
raconter ça c'est pour vous étiez jeune
avocat avocats stagiaires
quand il y avait des procès fait aux
militants du fln il disait demander des
citoyens algériens alors le à chaque
fois le biologiste disait il en est la
coiffe des juges disait mais y'a pas
d'algérie après département français -
et là quand je veux comme témoin des
procès de base qui disent on est on est
on est parce qu on n'est pas français le
président leur dit y'a pas de d'état
basque et alors ça s'engueule et les
bases se met à hurler en basque le
président comprend rien
bon et puis et puis voilà non c'est ce
que c'est ce que vergès appelle la
stratégie de rupture certain moment on
discute plus on est on est algérien on
est base bravo c'est pas grave alors ce
qui est vrai aussi c'est vous vous
rappelez fort justement qu'à l'époque de
la crise algérienne mitterrand françois
était pour l'algérie française mais pire
que tout mendès france à et bien sûr en
début au début en 54 faut lire les
déclarations de mendès-france
mais tous toute la classe politique
l'algérie sur la foire est un bon alors
je
dit tout de même précisément ont fait
l'europe il ya plus de tragédies ne
vivons pas vulgaire oui vous dis pas ça
sur le mode de la tragédie ça peut se
passer gentiment vous êtes convaincant
jeudi
les basques ses trois cent mille peines
les basques du nom les basques français
entre guillemets la corse et 205 oui
surtout qu'on va récupérer la wallonie
et on va récupérer la wallonie clés la
france a existé un rêve fortement sous
louis xiv la corse et dvd ni la savoie
nil compter la salle du canton de nice
alors quand je vois des amis qu'ils
disent mais la france est menacée dans
son existence mais non réelle et non pas
dû alors il ya des solutions y avait
effectivement une solution qui était
intermédiaire qui était la
départementalisation qui avaient été
promises par françois mitterrand
promesses non tenues alors vous n'êtes
pas pour le vote parce que effectivement
si on fait voter les français pour
savoir s'il va l'être basque face ils
veulent l'indépendance des bases il ya
une majorité qui risque de dire non et
même vous dites que dans honor delà de
la frontière la maison il y aura pas une
majorité à banon mais chez nous c'est
ici au su du racb aussi aux non non bien
entendu il ya le mouvement
indépendantiste chez nous en français
est faible retrait dont ben oui mais en
même temps une fois qu'il y aura un état
basque au sud il exercera une attraction
très fort donc des liens ce nouveau on
n'est pas pressé il faut prendre son
temps il faut encore une fois ne vivons
pas ça sur le mode tragique ce n'est pas
l'algérie s'est pas l'algérie alors là
là où votre argumentation est plus
périlleuse et vous le savez bien c'est
quand vous parlez du terrorisme c'est
effectivement un peu difficile dans
votre lit pas ce que vous dites bas
pendant la guerre c'est comme ça qu'on
justifie toujours le terrorisme
évidemment il est des résistants qui
fait sauter des trains allemands et vous
dites que shamir arafat et mandela qui
aujourd'hui sont au panthéon de
l'humanité ont commencé quand même pas
remettre des bons de quoi donc vous avez
je dis pas à vous excuser le terrorisme
loin de là mais disons vous pensez qu à
un moment c'est peut-être la seule
solution pour y arriver
écoutez moi je dis que de toute façon
les situations ne se compare pas à se
compare pas la situation en espagne
du bon roi juan carlos à ce qu'était la
situation des noirs d'afrique du sud ce
serait absurde et même obsède
mais les processus sont les mêmes à
partir du moment où vous avez des gens
qui décident d'avoir recours à la
violence
il faut arrêter c'est bon mais on ne les
a pas il indiqué ça fait 30 ans que ça
puisque vous dites qu'il s'y est cassé
les dents oui vous dites quand quand il
n'y a pas un vrai soutien populaire
c'est en corse dans le débat
quand y'a pas un soutien populaire ça
donne la route armée fractionne la
fameuse raf allemande où cette injection
directe et l'on voit bien que le peuple
était pas d essais balayé oui en
quelques semaines en quelques mois
bon ça n'a pas fait long feu mais au
pays basque que ça fait trente ans plus
de 30 ans a dû penser que ça va durer
tout le temps quoi là il faut arrêter il
faut se mettre autour du tas d'une table
et parler tranquillement et sereinement
effet cessé de faire couler le sang
alors ce qui est extraordinaire c'est
que vous vous trouvez que juan carlos
est très bien sur la corse vous avez les
mêmes positions de crémant barre et vous
citer le général de gaulle donc voilà
fait la grande réconciliation
aucune force de nos jours ne peut
étouffer un peuple qui lutte pour son
indépendance
oui c'est de gaulle qui viennent ça il a
raison il a raison il faut il faut
écouter je dirais près c'est un parcours
du combattant qui est imposé à un peuple
qui lutte au sein indépendance parce que
la répression est terrible la répression
est terrible pour les bains histoire du
cadre familial les ordures et cetera bas
il a passé sur l'examen de passage
le peuple basque eux il mérite qu'on le
prenne en compte 1 voilà de l'est je
dirais les irlandais du nord c'est la
même chose
alors si on peut sauter cette étape là
de violence mettant oui bien caché là
vous avez sans doute c'est vrai que si
on avait pu à décoloniser d'algérie
comme le maroc ou la tunisie sort et est
plus sympa soirée d'accord beaucoup plus
alors alors après simplement la question
qu'on peut vous poser gilles perrault
c'est après parce que quand les bretons
vont nous dire nous on veut être
on veut être indépendant relié à
bruxelles c'est très clair au sein de
l'europe
et alors qu'est ce qu'il faut faire il
faut donner l'indépendance à la bretagne
mais écoutez on n'en est pas là les
brevets ne demande pas le rendez vous
même les corses ne demande pas sa voix
vous savez qu'en savoie il ya
mouvalloise y avait failli à sa voisine
du bon non il ya de vrai problème chez
nous c'est le problème corse et le
problème pas est ce que bon les records
se regarder ils veulent pas leur
indépendance
l'ailé les indépendantistes sont
minoritaires encore mais mais personne
ne dénonce et va la regarder on nous tue
à préfets devront nous dire mais là bas
tout le monde est indigné mais personne
ne fait ça c'est clair
alors on nous parle d'une piste agricole
et puis d'une piste intellectuelle
la semaine prochaine ce sera la piste
philatélie non rien ne nous ont rien
trouvé
alors il faut que les corses prennent
leurs affaires en main qu'on leur donne
donc là l'autre ennemi la plus large il
faut que les affaires corses soient
réglés 5 l'europe et encore une fois
c'est là où votre livre tombe à pic
parce que c'est vrai que tant qu'ils
avaient pas l'europe c'était compliqué
oui mais voilà comme vous dites très
bien on se retrouvera tous à bruxelles
voilà exactement alors dites-moi gilles
perrault aux européennes de 94,8
présenter sur une liste
on l'a beaucoup reproché où il y avait
on a dit des fascistes flamand et
alsaciens donc cela la retrouve jusqu'à
présent le trouve très sympathique le
fait voulu l'indépendance des basses
mais quand vous présentez dans une dans
une liste en 94 il ya le parti fédéral
flamand
c'est quand même un peu le revers de la
médaille la non alors là écoutez moi
sont des amis basques qui m'ont demandé
de me présenter sur cette liste qui a
été un peu un peu improvisé au dernier
moment et il ya 87 candidats comme vous
savez il n'y a jamais eu de réunion de
l'ensemble de la liste
moi j'ai donné mon nom avec renault avec
d'anciens résistants très honorable et
c'est alors il parait effectivement
qu'il ya eu sur cette liste trois ou
quatre éléments un peu douteux dans la
dont l'un personnages pittoresques
d'après ce qu'on m'a dit un martiniquais
noir qui est devenu nationaliste flamand
oui bon c'est un peu bizarre comme
itinéraire mais ouais pourquoi pas enfin
bon pourquoi pas non bah oui voilà ça je
dois dire alors j'espère l'année
dernière dans cette émission n'avait
didier daeninckx
si vous attaquez vous avez fait le goût
du secret lui l'a fait le goût de la
vérité
il vous est attaqué on vous avait
demandé de devenir patrice carmouze vous
est demandé de venir répondre à donner
j'ai dû coûter non je parle ni répondra
de nice mais la prochaine fois que je
viendrais sur votre plateau
effectivement je remettrai de 3 pendules
à l'heure donc ce que je propose c'est
qu'on regarde un petit bout de
l'interview de nan c'est ensuite gilbert
aura comme c'est normal le loisir de son
droit de réponse magnéto il ya des gens
qui me disent attention et gilles
perrault c'est un ancien parachutiste
volontaire de la guerre d'algérie il
était proche de bigeard il a écrit des
horreurs sur sur la torture et où je n'y
crois pas je vais à la bibliothèque
nationale
je retrouve les bouquins de gilles
perrault et là je tombe du placard c'est
à dire je lis des choses absolument
incroyable le livre les parachutistes de
gilles perrault est un bouquin pré
fasciste
bon c'est dur à entendre rigolo alors je
reprend les arguments de langue si vous
pouvez me répondre au fur et à mesure
puisque vous êtes on vous donne
évidemment c'est tout à fait naturel la
possibilité de répondre
donc on viendra après aux parachutistes
lui disait finalement il ya un bouquin
qui avait été écrit par dové quadruppani
qui sont d'anciens disons intellectuels
qui ont flirté avec la vieille taupe et
les négationnistes et il avait écrit un
livre justement pour se dédouaner ses
deux garçons qui s'appelait libertaire
et ultra gauche contre le négationnisme
et vous vous avez accepté de faire la
préface de ce livre et daeninckx vous
reprocher
disait dans ce livre la pm toujours des
séquelles négationnistes et gilles
perrault fait la préface on le faisait
partie de ralph rompt avec daeninckx 1
contre contre le pen contre l'extrême
droite
vous avez refusé de paraît-il vous allez
répondre mais refusez de vous expliquer
auprès de la direction de ras le front
vous avez démissionné
ra le froid plus ou moins éclaté voilà
donc sur cela c'est la handicaper disant
non pas du tout non écoutés en matière
de révisionnisme et un expert en tout
cas pour moi il ya une autorité
incontournable
vidal naquet il approuve la peau la
brochure que j'ai préféré c'est à partir
de ce moment-là terminée non mais
d'accord qui est bonne réponse dans tous
les cas vidal naquet on peut être tout
le monde peut être que dalle
alors donc de lynx lit les parachutistes
est d'ailleurs sur les parachutistes est
votre premier succès il faut le dire et
vous le dit d'ailleurs j'ai vu l'autre
jour le le dire quelque part avec edwy
plenel et rabih où vous disiez
effectivement c'est vrai que j'ai
confondu
c'est vrai que moi pendant la guerre
j'ai été sauvé par les parachutistes que
quand je me suis engagé dans la guerre
d'algérie siéger volontaires les parages
suite il s'était des mec formidable et
en fait j'ai compris après que les
résistances étaient les algériens alors
ça vous le reconnaissez faut pas écouter
les parachutistes mon livre mon petit
livre écrit en 1961 a reçu le prix
aujourd'hui
c'était la première fois qu'on le
décernait vous avez un prix qu'yvan et
c'est le jury était composé d'anciens
résistants comme andré frossard et
cetera je ne vois pas ces gens-là
couronner un livre préfacé schiste et un
article qui a lancé ce livre qui a eu un
certain succès oui il est beaucoup c'est
grâce à lui que j'ai continué à écrire
il ya un article comme ça arrive
quelquefois un grand article qui a
déclenché la mécanique
c'était dans le canard enchaîné de
morvan lebesque qui disait le livre
était paru en décembre c'est le livre le
plus important de l'année
bon est ce que vous voyez le canard
enchaîné aujourd'hui hier ou avant-hier
louangé ainsi un livre préfacé schiste
alors écoutez je dois dire avant de
continuer de 100 corps deux points à
voir l'année dernière quand on est fait
de nice on avait donné la parole non pas
à vous que j'ai pas voulu venir mais à
jean françois kahn web à eyl et
jean-françois vous avez soutenu abazid à
ce que dit de nice en revanche il dit
dans la bibliographie de perrault les
parachutistes apparaît en premier et on
fait perreault a fait treize livres
avant alors dynamite au pied du mur la
main rouge le sahara brûle lui qualifie
ses 13 premiers livres de rouge brun sas
et je repars des romans d'aventurés moi
pourquoi j'ai commencé à écrire quand
j'ai fait mon service
j'avais deux enfants et j'avais pas
d'économie rien et la solde
moi celle ci je faisais mon service j'ai
pas du tout j'étais caporal-chef 20
conduit j'étais proche de bigeard n'est
même pas dans le régiment de blizzard
j'étais caporal-chef troufions 1 et il
fallait que je fasse vivre ma famille et
j'ai donc commencé à écrire des romans
de quat'sous magic serveur d'une semaine
mais qui était ni rouge ni brun qui
étaient des rois en avant je n'étais pas
dans ça m'angoisse était strictement
terre
j'ai pas envie qu'on me juge à partir de
ça c'était vraiment pour la normalité
voilà vous êtes eux explique et je vous
en remercie parce qu'on tient ici est ce
qu'une espèce de rectitude gentil de me
permettre d'en écouter tout ça je n'ai
pas toutes les vertus je n'ai pas non
plus tout où tous les défauts j'ai
commis des erreurs dans ma vie ma peu la
première erreur c'est de ne pas avoir
compris évidemment ce que c'était que
cette guerre d'algérie moi je j'ai voulu
faire mon service dans les parachutistes
voilà je les fais c'est probablement
l'erreur politique de ma vie en face à
va voilà il ya eu pire merci beaucoup
donc je répète le titre du livre lettre
ouverte à deux juges françaises décoré
de la cruz des au nord de la lorraine
dessin raimundo des peña forte chez
fayard merci bravo pour les filles c'est
sympa pour les présentateurs des travaux
pour l'acsa je reçois maintenant bernard
henri lévy pour la parution au livre de
poche dans la collection biblio et ces
deux questions de principe 6 intitulé
avec salman rushdie une série d'articles
de presse et de lettres ouvertes dans
lesquels bhl se bat comme un beau diable
pour défendre l'auteur des versets
sataniques bref un livre ou rushdie ce
débat et où les vies des bas bonsoir
alors question de principe hisse donc
c'est des textes qui sont parues dans le
figaro dans match dans l'oeuvre dans le
monde enfin finalement il ya il ya sept
texan retouches comme d'habitude dans
votre série il n'y a pas de sap a été
corrigé par la suite
donc on va parler de ça on va commencer
par ça donc les versets sataniques je
rappelle un peu la faire à février 89
des manifestations aux en inde et au
pakistan
le livre brûlé l'éffigie de l'auteur
brûlé et à ce moment-là l'ayatollah
khomeini décide de lancer la fatwa c'est
à dire que tout musulman doit a pour
mission divine de tué salman rushdie et
donc vous ça déclenche chez vous une
volonté de combattre sa pétition
émissions débats colloques etc
c'est d'affaires se résume comme ça
alors dans un premier temps vous
raconter c'est dans votre bouquin il ya
eu l'idée d'une édition collectif c'est
à dire que tous les éditeurs français se
serait finalement associé pour sortir
chacun sous leur nom les verser cette
année pourquoi ça s'est pas fait oui
parce que d'ailleurs à 1,7
cette mobilisation s'est passé pas celle
de telle ou telle je crois que
l'ensemble de l'intelligentia et des
éditeurs se sont sentis concernés par
cette fatwa contre salman rushdie et à
l'époque il avait une initiative dont je
me demande d'ailleurs si elle ne venait
pas de jean-claude fasquelle
initialement jeu peut-être fasquelle et
durant je ne sais plus visant à éditer
le livre que l'équipement pourquoi ça ne
s'est pas fait parce que bourgois l'a
fait non sans courage d'ailleurs parce
qu'il fallait à l'époque un peu d'audace
je crois c'était l'époque où on
assassine et l traducteur de salma nous
ont posé des bombes chez pol éditeur
étranger et donc ça bon christian
bourgois a fait son effet son métier il
a fait 13 avril d assassiner il n'a pas
été sélectionné grâce au méridien
l'avait sorti non l'idiot international
n'avait pas il me semble qu'ils avaient
sorti quelques quelques extraits aussi
un moment votre j'irai pas votre ami
parce que c'est vous étiez pas
spécialement proche de jean edern
hallier
oui enfin en tout cas je suis proche de
ses nombreux jeudi et ça je ne m'en
souviens pas bien alors vous raconter
mais peut-être après touche d'enseignés
votre première rencontre avec eux jeudi
à l un qui est hélas en faites vous
celui que vous preniez pour un symbole
en fait vous devenez assez rapidement
ami avec lui c'est assez vous découvre
un homme jeune plein de drôles l'air
drôle on voit là la première chose qui
m'avait qui m'a frappé et qui n'a cessé
de me frapper d'ailleurs après au tout
au fil de ces de ces rencontres
nombreuses celles à l'humour
extraordinaire de cet homme ce type
traqués et pourchassés qui ne s'est pas
chaque matin s'il serait encore vivant
le soir qui ne s'est pas le soir en se
couchant ce qu il se réveillera vivant
si j'ose dire lendemain matin cet
homme-là est extraordinairement drôle
le premier soir je me souviens c'était
nous avions passé la soirée à blaguer
sur lesdits dayez sur le prince charles
sur la famille royale d'angleterre ils
connaissent tous les potins et ses 2
voilà il était il est il était et il est
encore aujourd'hui
irrésistible alors à ce moment là là la
france refuse de le recevoir et en
blaguant et vous dis d'ailleurs vous qui
avez fait et vous qui avait amené
françois mitterrand à sarajevo
vous pouvez faire quelque chose pour moi
à quoi celui qui croyait des choses là
effectivement ce restaurant vous allez
d'abord vous découvrez que le choix du
resto c'est pas facile quand on est avec
salman rushdie sait pas où on va on va
dîner là on va dîner là et alors ils
vous racontent l'histoire de cette chère
à la fin du à la fin du repas vous en
souvenez le maître d'hôtel lui dit
qu'est ce que madame qu'est-ce que vous
prenez
steck t il demandé pour les légumes
hastac aussi les légumes étant les mines
et elle croit que c'est des ministres
restaurant le premier jour c'est assez
bien mais aussi de l'histoire de là
c'est pour ça c'est un grand écrivain
mais c'est aussi encore une fois un type
très drôle histoire de la photo aussi de
micheline pelletier sur cette photo qui
se fait dehors parce qu'on le voyait
toujours à l'intérieur et la photo est
fait au grand jour et pendant les trois
minutes je crois que c'est la première
photo de salman en liberté photo qui
donne le sentiment de d'ouverture de
gaieté de vue et de liberté est en effet
j'ai vu faire cette photo la préparation
les les gign ou assimilés puisqu'on
était à l'époque en finlande au tour
tous cette espèce de déploiement
policier considérable pour arriver à
arranger juste une photo au destin et à
l'horreur une seconde de la liberté
d'apparence de liberté alors triomphe de
la société du spectacle bien sûr d'un
côté et puis d'un autre côté je crois
que c'était important symbole and
d'envoyer ce message aux ayatollahs
parce que c'est ça qui n'a cessé de
faire pendant dix ans et chaque fois
qu'on se rencontre est encore une fois à
paris à londres wire l'obsession c'était
toujours celle là il a vécu pendant ces
dix années avec la le spectre de
khomeiny auto au dessus de sa tête lui
montrer que je suis libre lui montrer
que je n'arrête pas d'écrire lui montrer
que je continue d'aller dans un
restaurant avec des copains lui montrais
je peux marcher dans les rues de londres
ça c'était cette rencontre que je
racontais on en parle papier du monde
voilà alors après bon en fait il ya une
lettre dans le bouquin une lettre à
dumas parce que mitterrand dit rien
chirac dit toute façon ça ne malheureuse
10 un blasphémateur et qu'il n'aime pas
qu'on gagne de l'argent avec les places
faible celui qui finalement le fera
rentrer ça sera jack lang est la règle
du jeu la revue que celui que vous
dirigez alors et grâce à jack lang qui
là dessus d'ailleurs n'a jamais jamais
molli quoi malgré mitterrand malgré
malgré le cynisme d'état mitterrando
chiraquien asus est là dessus c'est la
même réaction sorte de programme commun
aux idées des deux présidents justement
vous de rencontrer à londres à
l'initiative du nouvel obs
je crois avec catherine chemla exiger
non pardon est donc là vous avez une
conversion qui est assez intéressante
parce que parler des médias justement ça
vous parlez de bourdieu de derrida debré
et lui dit quelque chose c'est ce qu'ils
montrent d'ailleurs que effectivement il
faut pas qu'on passe à la télé on
demande après comment était et c'est une
question d'une obscénité total mais à
laquelle finalement nul n'échappe quoi
et là vous avez une discussion sur
est-ce que l'expression de la pensée
compatible avec les médias audiovisuels
alors ça c'est un sujet que vous
connaissez bien aussi oui mais dont
l'information c'est pas que je connais
c'est au goût de tout le monde le sait
hélas mais lui le connaît très bien sait
bien que dans cette conversation il
apparaît comme un écrivain juste normal
c'est à dire quelqu'un qui réfléchit à
ça la pollution par les médias ou au
contraire au passage d'un message à
travers les médias à la gloire et à ses
effets pervers il analysera tout ça
voilà c'est ce qu'il avait comme ça et
donc encore une fois il n'a pas été là
encore je pense qu'il faut saluer cette
espèce de force d'âme extraordinaire il
n'a jamais été mangé par son affaire ça
a été son obsession ne pas être un
symbole sur pattes ne pas être une fatwa
vivante mais il ya réussi il reste un
écrivain normal qu'ils se posent des
problèmes normaux qui réfléchit comme
chacun d'entre nous ce qui transparaît
alors pour en finir avec crunch dit le
vrai problème c'est l'islam quand même
fini par dire c'est à dire que il ya il
ya quelque chose qui apparaît à la fin
du livre c'est que finalement
aujourd'hui le problème c'est l'islam
c'est-à-dire cette espèce d'islam très
intégristes et que finalement il
faudrait avoir le courage aujourd'hui
comme on l'a fait enfin quand peu de
gens l'ont fait à l'époque du communisme
de dire le roi est nu
c'est en effet ce a pris sa position
dans une de nos dernières rencontres ou
peut-être la dernière d'ailleurs que je
rapporte ans et la dernière la dernière
c'est ça il dit oui est ce qu'on peut
continuer éternellement de dire bon il
ya un islam corrompu et mortifère b il
ya un autre islam idéal pour l'ami ne me
condamnerait pas alors moi je pense
plutôt que oui je pense qu'il reste un
islam des lumières démocratique qui est
encore vivant et qui l'emportera
j'espère que j'ai rencontrés sur
d'autres théâtres du monde en
afghanistan par exemple wire et lui ce
jour là était peut-être plus nuancée ou
plus pessimiste il semblait penser en
effet qu'il y avait au coeur même de
l'islam
et ça c'est en effet un vrai débat au
coeur même de l'islam quelque chose qui
n'était pas incompatible hélas avec le
fait de bafouer les droits de l'homme ou
de lancer une fatwa contre un grand
écrivain
alors quand vous écrivez ça
effectivement on entend le grésillement
deux lauréats trois visites vous prenez
du plaisir quand même d'être là avec lui
quand vous parlez du grésillement de
l'oreillette du garde du corps c'est à
dire que quand même vous faisiez vous
êtes tout à fait conscient de la
situation aussi accepté pour être abattu
par un sniper
je prends du plaisir parce que parce que
ce parce que cet homme est un parce que
je les admire que c'est un des plus
grands écrivains vivants et deux parce
que je laime c'est mon c'est devenu mon
ami ça ne l'était pas avant mais ce il
l'est devenu
et donc chacune de ces rencontres est en
effet un moment très agréable
à part ça c'est vrai qu'on ne peut pas
passer deux heures
enfin c'est d'ailleurs très étrange
quand on est avec salman rushdie il ya
toujours un moment où on oublie la fatwa
où on a l'impression encore une fois que
la vie est normale
et puis à un moment où le destin le
rattraperait olio ces mêmes vous savez
je pense d'ailleurs qu'il a probablement
je le dis abandonné dans une de nos
rencontres une espèce de petit compteur
dans la tête qui fait qu'à dès qu'il
apparaît quelque part il sait qu'il a
une heure deux heures 5 heures on le
retrouve le temps qu'on le retrouve dès
qu'il apparaît dans les tueurs sont en
route et
et voilà d'ailleurs c'est très très bien
dit c'est vrai qu'à un moment donné la
fausse nouvelle c'est tout le monde
annonce qui va être libre enfin que la
fatwa va être supprimée en fait c'est
pas vrai et quand il est finalement la
fatwa est enlevée vous terminez en
disant qu il peut toujours y avoir un
tueur isolé de toute façon qui lui ne
veut pas tenir compte de ça et
l'expression ces fatwas miniaturisés
c'est assez bien sûr il lui la vie avec
toi avec sabrina il vivra dans sa vie
probablement avec ça mais encore une
fois il le fait avec un courage
extraordinaire
il ya des rencontres que je n'ai pas
rapportée dans ce livre parce qu'elle
était de l'ordre du privé et je dois
dire je dirais et qui sont qui sont
encore plus étonnante
quant à cette capacité d'un homme traqué
pour chasser de vivre à peu près
normalement mais voilà des villes et
dans le nord il est mon point de vue il
s'agit de continuer je vous presse un
peu je suis désolé mais quand on regarde
un peu ce que vous avez fait depuis le
milieu des années 70 vous avez fait
beaucoup contre le communisme avec les
nouveaux philosophes enfin contre commis
pour faire prendre conscience aux gens
de la perversité du système commises
effet beaucoup aussi pour là pour faire
prendre conscience aux gens de la
réalité de la période de vichy
d'occupation qui avait été effectivement
un peu occulté par le mythe résistance
y'a listes soutenues à la fois par les
gaullistes et par les communistes donc
effectivement il y avait une prise de
conscience
une seule question parce que marc
lambron qui était le premier invité de
cette émission il ya deux ans à l'époque
de 1941
la question qui se pose est dans son
livre c est ce que vichy est explicable
et j'ai envie de vous poser la même
c'est à dire que est ce qu'après le
discours de chirac commémoratif de la
rafle du vel d'hiv
est-ce que voilà le président a des
excuses disons est ce que vous pensez
que vichy est explicable est-ce que vous
pensez que comme quand on lit
l'idéologie française c'est un peu peggy
c'est pétain est ce que vous pensez que
la france c'est pétain et que finalement
cette tâche restera comme sur la tunique
de nessus non non je ne pense pas ça je
pense que d'abord je pense pas que la
france est bien je pense que la france
et pétain et de gaulle que la france est
c'est l'un famille et la résistance
c'est les deux voilà alors expliquer ça
veut dire quoi dire qu'à un moment voilà
c'est fini un moment on dit bon bah
comme les allemands du voilà ils ont
fait ça m'a donc j'y parvenais je crois
que oui pardonner bien sûr mais ça veut
pas dire fini par donner ça ne veut pas
dire fini par donner ce bad est obligé
de sagou dit ouais pardonner ça veut pas
dire occulter ça veut dire que je crois
qu'un peuple devient malade s'ils
décident arbitrairement par décret de
renvoyer dans l'est dans les poubelles
de sa mémoire ou dans la cour je ne sais
quel inconscient une partie de son
histoire
je crois qu'il faut pas demander ça aux
français ce serait un apparent
soulagement nous demander ça serait un
apparent soulagement et serait en
réalité un poids terrible à porter alors
donc je vous tiens on va faire avant de
terminer on va dire un mot du kosovo je
lisais à papier l'autre jour où vous
critiquiez régis debray pour avoir parlé
de l'amérique intérieur enfin et vous
disiez c'est là où temps en temps vous
allez très vite et très loin vous dites
que ça me faisait penser à valois qui
est le créateur du fascisme français à
drieu la rochelle est ce que le fait de
dire que finalement on et par
capillarité habité par l'amérique parce
que voilà ça date de la fin de la guerre
est ce que le fait de remettre en
question cette présence américaine n'ont
pas les bases mais dans nos têtes
est-ce que vous pensez que celle d'un
seul coup ça rapproche quiconque de
george baloi ou de rio la roja bien sûr
que non je ne disais pas ça mais je
disais en revanche et ça
régis debray est un intellectuel donc il
est il est tissée de mots c'est un homme
livre comme moi comme c'est notre
substance amérique intérieur dans
l'histoire de l'idéologie française
c'est un concept très précis en effet
l'idée que l'amérique n'est pas
seulement une région du monde mexicaine
région de la tête d'une région de l'être
cette idée là elle a une acte un acte de
naissance dans l'histoire des idées et
elle charrie qu'on le veuille ou non
avec elle dans l'inconscient il ya un
inconscient des langues politique il ya
un inconscient de la révéler au plus de
sens que leur centre c'est clair voilà
les mots sont plus lourds en effet plus
chargé que ce qu'il
n'ont l'air de dire c'est pas seulement
des véhicules ont tout cassé des
véhicules ouais coffre arrière est
chargé alors quand vous parlez de la
guerre en ce moment au kosovo vous dit
que c'est une guerre juste là évidemment
ce qu'on serait en droit de vous de vous
dire section part en croisade contre
tous les tyrans de la planète et contre
tous les pays qui en maltraite d'autres
c'est la guerre at vitam aeternam parce
que faudra s'occuper des des kurdes des
palestiniens des tibétains dessus pour
s'occuper des kurdes et les palestiniens
des timorés des dix mort et orientaux
est ce que vous croyez pas la question
est celle là est ce que vous croyez pas
de cette façon de vouloir exporter les
droits de l'homme ça correspond un peu
finalement à ce qui s'est passé avec la
colonisation quand des gens bien
intentionnés comme jules ferry ont voulu
exporter dans le monde entier liberté
égalité fraternité etc et c'est avec la
canonnière que souvent on a imposé à la
population que rien à faire les notions
de liberté d'égalité est ce
qu'aujourd'hui on n'est pas en train
d'expliquer aux serbes avec des
bombardements qu'il faut qu'il soit pour
les droits de l'homme est ce que c'est
pas de l'europe et au centrisme ça de
vouloir que tout le monde adopte des
droits de l'homme
premièrement la colonisation c'est pas
les droits de l'homme qu'elle exportait
que je sache
c'était la république française on
voulait pas vraiment l'homme s'était dit
pendant c'était une citoyenneté de
seconde zone où il y avait des gens qui
étaient plus ou moins 1 100 milliards
des droits de l'homme vers de l'ambition
c'était d'en faire des français en leur
apprenant missions étendues que ces cons
là on leur expliquait gas algérie
c'était leurs ancêtres il n'a pas le
droit de vote en tout cas pas comme des
français normaux donc on crée pas la
république française une et indivisible
on créer une citoyenneté de seconde zone
numéro un numéro 2 est-ce qu'on force
les serbes être européen
les serbes sont européens moi je pense
que le rapport au père est ce qu on leur
apprend pas les droits de l'homme de
force en les bombardant est ce que tout
le monde a envie de sutter est ce que
tout le monde doit vivre selon cette
idéologie des droits dans la scala
dossier voilà ça c'est une vraie
question moi je crois que les droits de
l'homme c'est mieux que la barbarie
je crois que le peuple sont plus heureux
oui que les femmes africaines sont plus
heureuse quand elles sont pas excisée
que quand elles le sont je crois que les
kosovars sont plus heureux quand ils
vivent dans leur village que quand ils
sont déportés et je crois que les serbes
à l'arrivée comme les allemands 44 ils
seront mieux quand ils vivront dans un
état de droit que sous la botte d'un
tyran sanguinaire alors pour finir
dernière question
à l'époque vous avez n'ont pas été
maoïste faut être clair vais jamais été
dans la gauche prolétarienne comme serge
july comme claude jambes enfin vous avez
fleurs terre un peu avec le maoïsme et
quand on vous demandait je vous
demandais ya dix ans dans une autre
émission je vous disais mais enfin
pourquoi avez-vous flirte avec le
maoïsme et vous me disiez ben oui
c'était la notion d'un avant et d'un
après c'est à dire on voulait valider
mao et ceux qui pensaient un peu comme
lui c'est être cassé en deux l'histoire
du monde en finir avec l'histoire du
malheur c'est à dire que cette idée car
il y avait un avant marocain après mao
est ce que maintenant vous n'êtes pas
encore en train de vous tromper est ce
que vous pouvez pas vous demander si
vous n'êtes pas encore en train de vous
tromper aujourd'hui en voulant
absolument à l'époque qui est un avant
et un après chacun avant droits de
l'homme et un monde des droits de
l'homme est ce que ce n'est pas encore
une grande illusion messianique de plus
comme le maoïsme a pu l'être
la grande différence avec l'époque
maurice s'est que très franchement sur
ce terrain là je ne pousse pas des
questions aussi compliqué je me pose des
questions compliquées dans d'autres
domaines et zafy en littérature mais pas
là dessus
ma seule question aujourd'hui c'est
comment faire pour que les kosovars
rentrer chez eux
comment faire pour qu'il vive en paix
pour moi c'est le seul musée un bateau
pour le vietnam
comment des choses pratiques oui oui
enfin on s'ouvre les gens et comment
faire pour que les serbes qui mérite
quand même mieux que cette espèce de
pantin de marionnettes de soi même
absurde et et sanguinaire comment faire
pour qu'il vive dans un régime normal
pour eux en tout elle pour ranger
brillant contre les serbes
bien sûr que non j'ai souvent quand on
lit vos écrits on a l'impression qu'il
ya aucun serbe qui trouve grâce à vos
yeux alors que l'epa vrai notre pensée
au contraire au contraire j'ai des
nombreuses occasions de dire le
contraire je suis allé à belgrade
pendant la guerre de bosnie à l'époque
où l'essai où l'armée cernent bombardé
sarajevo
je suis allé à l'invitation des
étudiants de belgrade à belgrade en 93
et 94 parlait dans des amphithéâtres
d'étudiants mais leur tenir le même
langage que celui que je tenais à
sarajevo bien maintenant c'est à dire
vos dirigeants sont sont des barbares
très bien merci doit la gelée poser
toutes les questions je voulais vous
poser donc je rappelle le titre du livre
ces questions de principe numéro 6 donc
ça c'est avec salman rushdie consacré
donc à l'expérience vous voyez encore
comme c'est maintenant je dis maintenant
lui ne s'arrête pas à la fin de ce livre
sûrement pas merci pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de l'inaptitude abonnez vous
mettez un pouce bleus